we actually still live in the same house
because uh we get along really well
not only is anderson cooper co-parenting
with his
ex-boyfriend but he just revealed they
also
live together it's yeah it's weird but
uh it works out the cnn anchor made an
appearance on the ellen degeneres show
on wednesday
where he opened up about being a new dad
to his son wyatt
and how he's balancing daddy duties with
his ex
benjamin masani who anderson says
initially
wasn't so sure about having a kid it was
interesting because he wasn't
really sure he wanted to have a kid
which was one of the reasons we probably
broke up
um but then he came around the idea and
now he is
just such a great parent in fact the 53
year old news anchor says becoming a dad
has turned benjamin
into a big softy but all this time
together
doesn't necessarily mean the two will
rekindle their love
well maybe all we'll get back together
because now maybe okay
that felt like a hard no to me but
anderson
isn't ruling out the idea of baby number
two now do you think that you want wyatt
to have a sibling are you gonna have
another baby i
you know i don't know i i i there's
nothing in the works but
um i you know i don't know
i would yes i mean i would love to i
would love to
i think it'd be great for him to to have
a yeah i'm not sure i can handle like
another but
he's he's really such an easy kid for
now the tv personality says he's
just enjoying all those bliss-filled
baby wyatt moments
he's still sleeping like 12 and a half
hours every night he
eats his sweet peas and his mushed
cauliflower
and yeah he's just um he's just a happy
little chappie
it's such a joy anderson first
introduced his son to the world in may
2020 fighting back tears live on air
as a gay kid i never thought it would be
possible to have a child
and i'm so grateful for all those who
paved the way wyatt's arrival came less
than a year after anderson's mom
gloria vanderbilt died at the age of 95
when et spoke with the mother-son duo
in 2016 gloria said she hoped her son
would have a child of his own one day
thanks for bringing this up this is not
as if this isn't an ongoing issue
doesn't every mother want their kid to
have yes i've heard this many times
believe me
i know the clock is ticking and earlier
this week
anderson summed up parenthood with one
little word
sharing this shot with his baby boy on
instagram
alongside the caption bliss